here's the deal
I played this one with the black I
didn't get white next day let's go
[Laughter]
[Music]
French is very fast as long as he
doesn't drop pieces Wow an accelerated
mosaic line looks like iron is not too
impressed though and let's got himself a
lot of weaknesses a weakened Kings
position I would not recommend this to
anyone
once again iron is playing very
classical chess and this is the region
and world junior champion folks this is
not a nobody Sebastian is trying to
complicate the game and we will see if
you succeed but I don't keeping control
win me back by a pawn but at the very
least bus and I simplified and maybe
have some hope on the clock here he goes
that was a cunning plan I have to say
[Music]
he's got everything under control
right in this running with the pawn I am
trying to flag but is it gonna be enough
[Music]
desperately trying to win on time again
it looks like it's gonna be made pretty
soon where was the Queen there are some
doubts about it and there's the mate
with one second to go I have to say
though that I am played fast once again
so